AI TAKING OVER:
“AI will replace our jobs”. This is the most
ridiculous statement I’ve ever heard. Eversince
ChatGPT came out, there’s been this general fear
that AI will replace everyone’s jobs and that
all of our skills will suddenly become completely
useless. And it’s not surprising why people think
this. For one, people have seen these tools in
action first hand. They’ve seen realistic photos
spawning out of thin air, 3000 word essays being
typed out in 30 seconds, and hundreds of line code
being drafted up like it’s nothing. At the same
time, we also have all these articles that are
like AI will replace 47% of all US jobs within
the next 20 years or AI is set to replace 300
million jobs or AI could replace up to 8 in 10
jobs, expert says. And it’s not just journalists
and media organizations who are making these bold
claims either. We have valedictorians from the
most elite colleges and CEOs from the biggest tech
companies that are all propagating this notion.
Elon, for example, has been claiming that we’ll
all need universal basic income because robots
will take all our jobs. Meanwhile, Sundar Pichai
has been preaching that AI could be more profound
than fire or electricity. But, you wanna know
a secret? Sundar has been saying the exact same
thing for over 5 years now. That’s just his go to
statement when he’s pitching the importance and
impact of Google’s AI. Also, remember that study
that was suggesting that 47% of all US jobs will
be replaced by AI within the next 20 years?
Well, that study was published 10 years ago,
so theoretically, we should already be feeling the
pain. Yet, unemployment is still at near all time
lows despite recession fears, high inflation, high
interest rates, and apparently AI taking over.
And the reason is obvious, AI is not going
leave all of us jobless relying on some sort
of UBI from the government because AI will not
be replacing the value of humans, let me explain.
HUMAN RESILIENCE:
To understand why AI doesn’t stand a chance,
all we have to do is look back at history. In
fact, we can rewind 12,000 years to the year
10,000 BC. This probably feels like forever
ago but in the context of human development,
it’s actually extremely recent. Modern humans are
thought to have come about sometime within the
past 200 to 300,000 years, so 10,000 BC is part
of the most recent 5% of human history. Up until
this point, the life of the average human was
pretty simple. Virtually every single human spent
the vast majority of their time on survival. They
would hunt for animals, gather berries and water,
create weapons using rocks and sticks, and ignite
fires to keep them warm and cook food. Basically
all of their time was just spent on survival. But,
somehow, around this time, some idiots around the
world figured out that if you put a seed into
the ground, pour some water on it, and give it
some time, you could produce food on demand.
Now, imagine if these nomads were like “Brooo,
if we could just scale this agriculture thing,
man no one would have to work anymore especially
if we got good at it. Imagine if just 1% of the
population could make enough food for everyone.
Then we could all just sit around and never have
to worry about survival again.” Oh wait, that’s
exactly how it is today. Most people in western
countries never have to worry about food but
98.7% of Americans are not unemployed. In fact,
it’s the other way around. The people who produce
all of our food are usually the least paid, the
least respected, and the least valued even though
they often work the longest, the hardest, and
are essential to our survival. Now, theoretically
speaking we could’ve made that nomad dream a
reality. We could’ve had some sort of system where
all of us only have to work like 1 week every
year on the fields. The rest of the time, we could
just sit in our huts and have food handed to us.
Thinking back, this did start to happen. As the
efficiency of agriculture skyrocketed the amount
of free time people had also skyrocketed. But
people didn’t just opt to sit around; instead,
they started mastering crafts. They became
skilled bakers, carpenters, butchers, soldiers,
stonemasons, and tailors. We spent our time
building entire cities with hundreds of roles,
jobs, and mechanics all centered around these
agricultural hubs. And agriculture is just one
example. Such shifts have occurred thousands of
times during human history during the advents of
concrete, electricity, light bulbs, telephones,
locomotives, cars, planes, trucks, highways,
vaccines, computers, smartphones, the internet,
and who knows what else. I mean just think
about this. 60% of all workers are currently in
occupations that did not even exist in 1940. Let
me phrase that in a different way. The majority
of all working people are working at jobs that
did not even exist a single lifetime ago. So,
how in the world is the advent of AI any
different from what we’ve been doing over the past
12,000 years? Well, many would argue that it’s the
speed of AI progress that makes it so dangerous.
Not only will AI replace low level factory jobs or
cashier jobs but it’ll also replace white collar
jobs like doctors, lawyers, and engineers. And
to this, I once again call BS. Let me explain.
THIS TIME IS NOT DIFFERENT:
People often like to claim that it’s the speed
of AI advancement that makes it so disruptive
but this too is easily disprovable. Yes, AI is
advancing faster than anything we’ve seen before
but guess what so did every other revolutionary
technology. That’s kind of why it’s revolutionary.
It took agriculture 10,000 years to catch
on but it only took a thousand years for
cities to catch on. It only took hundreds of
years for electricity, only decades for tech,
and only took years for smartphones. So, it’s only
natural that AI is able to catch on within months
but really it’s not even that fast. Researchers
predict that AI’s computational power will double
every 6 to 10 months. But this isn’t even all that
crazy when you consider Moore’s law. Back in 1965,
Gordon Moore, the eventual founder of Intel,
predicted that the number of transistors on
integrated circuits will double every single year
and he was spot on. Over the next 10 years, the
number of transistors on microchips jumped from a
few hundred to tens of thousands. But after this
fast initial jump, Gordon would actually revise
his prediction as progress slowed to transistors
doubling every 2 years which has largely held true
over the past 50 years. So, objectively speaking,
the intelligence of tech was advancing the
fastest back in the late 60s and early 70s.
But if you extrapolated that to argue that
this was the fastest period of tech adoption,
you would’ve been completely wrong. Microsoft
and Apple weren’t even a thing yet. And there
was still decades till Google and Facebook
would even be founded. Really, it wasn’t till
the 2000s and especially after the launch of the
iPhone that tech adoption became ubiquitous. Now,
this isn’t to say that it’ll take decades for AI
to become ubiquitous. It’s obviously advancing
and being adopted faster than computers but
it’s still naturally going to take time.
The bottomline is that with each and every
one of these revolutionary introductions,
it’s humans who are creating these changes and
propagating them. So, naturally, these changes
will be limited by the laws of supply and demand.
Just because you make a great AI doesn’t mean that
it’ll be instantly adopted. It’ll only be adopted
when there is a demand for it and there will only
be an demand for it when the technology and
a large portion of society are ready for it.
So, this time is not different. In fact, I’d
wager that AI will actually catch on much slower
than you might expect and the best example of
this is the failed automation of factories.
THE AUTOMATION THAT NEVER HAPPENED:
Before everyone was worried about AI taking
over white collar jobs, people were scared
about automation taking over factory jobs.
And this makes sense given that back in 1979,
factory employment was at an all time high. 19.6
million Americans worked factory jobs, so fancy
robot arms and assembly lines obviously made
them feel uneasy. And they were right, factory
jobs did indeed decline by 35%....over the next 40
years. In other words, all of these crazy computer
chips that went from a thousand transistors
to 50 billion transistors weren’t even able
to eliminate half of factory jobs over the next 40
years. They weren’t even eliminating 1% per year.
And that’s not even accounting for all of the
factory jobs that were shipped overseas as opposed
to being replaced by robots. The number one
reason for this is that robots suck at handling
edge cases. Our AI overlord Elon, is actually the
most familiar with this as he was nearly driven
into bankruptcy because of it. You see, as a
staunch AI and automation supporter, I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that Elon tried
to create a completely automated Tesla factory.
He hired the best software and AI engineers on the
planet, sunk billions of dollars into building his
grand gigafactory and had hundreds of thousands
of people waiting to receive their Model 3s.
Theoretically, all he had to do was press the go
button on the factory, deliver a bunch of cars,
and make a crap ton of money. Easy right?
Well, all of this changed when he actually
pressed the go button. There’s really no
pleasant way to put this. The reality was
that his automated factory was absolute trash.
One small misalignment in in the sheets of metal
and the robots couldn’t screw in the bolt.
One small misalignement in the paintshop,
and the robot would paint the window. Such matters
are trivial for humans to handle but for robots,
such matters made them completely ineffective.
Elon found himself constantly stopping the
production line to fix all the errors that
these robots were making. This destroyed the
productivity of his factories, leading to Tesla
burning billions of dollars and getting single
digit weeks away from bankruptcy. You know how
Tesla recovered from this manufacturing hell?
Well, everyone including the tech guys had to work
on the factory line and work 100 plus hours every
week just to get Tesla to stop burning cash.
Aka, Tesla had to deautomate their factory
and Elon would end up admitting “Yes, excessive
automation at Tesla was a mistake. To be precise,
my mistake. Humans are underrated.” If this is the
case with simple repetitive factory automation,
how in the world is it realistic to assume that
AI can just automate software engineering just
because it can write algorithms or solve hard
leetcode problems. It really makes no sense at
all. The vast majority of a software engineer's
time is not spent on doing the fun obvious stuff.
In fact, the obvious stuff takes no time at all.
The vast majority of time is spent on doing the
boring but essential stuff. How do we handle all
of these different errors? How do we scale this
code seamlessly? How do we address all the edge
cases? This is precisely where engineers spend
their time and this is precisely what AI cannot
do. I mean, just look at Tesla autopilot. They
were able to get lane assist on highways working
extremely fast, but getting it to work everywhere
else is proving extremely difficult. Now, with
that being said, it would also be stupid to think
that AI won’t affect software engineering. It
absolutely will but we’re talking about a slow
shift away like with manufacturing as opposed
to something that just transpires overnight
just because ChatGPT has a 100% accuracy on
Leetcode. And this brings us into the last
argument regarding AI replacing jobs which is
that it’ll replace more jobs than it creates.
THE JOB DEFICIT DEBUNKED:
The idea that AI will take away more jobs
than it creates is really quite stupid because AI
nor any new technology is not a zero sum game and
it’s quite limiting to look at it from that
perspective. Take the internet for example.
In the early days, the internet was largely used
for research purposes. What if people thought that
the internet would take away jobs just because
it would put a lot of libraries out of business
and in return only give a 1000 jobs to coders?
Obviously, that statement is laughable today but
is it really that far fetched back in the day?
40 years ago, no one would’ve even been able to
fathom the idea of multi hundred billion dollar
social media companies, e commerce platforms,
cloud providers, database solutions, streaming
giants, fintech offerings, food delivery, ride
sharing, online booking services, the list really
goes on forever. It’ll be the same way with AI.
From our current position, we can only envision
how AI will disrupt the jobs and careers that
we already know. We have no chance of even
conceptuatlizing all of the jobs and careers
that AI will create. 15 years ago, it wasn’t even
possible to make money as an “influencer”. Today,
being a YouTuber is the number 1 dream job in
America. Also, not only did tech create a bunch
of jobs but it created the new first class. Think
about all of the richest people in the world. They
are owners of tech companies, executives of
tech companies, employees of tech companies,
partners of tech companies, affiliates of
tech companies, investors of tech companies,
and so on. Truth be told, if you weren’t
involved in tech within the past 20 years,
you were probably left behind. And it’s no wonder
why. These companies are able to create value
faster and at larger scales than ever before.
This will only be truer with AI as AI makes work
magnitudes more efficient. So, not only will AI
not make everyone jobless hobos but it’ll actually
create an unprecedented number of insanely highly
paying jobs along with hundreds of trillionaires
because the only way that it plays out any
other way is if humans fundamentally change.
If humans fundamentally change and somehow
become satisfied with what we already have.
The current tech we have, the current economy
we have, and the current society that we have.
As long as people are always striving for more
and more, you can rest assured that we’ll never
end up in some sort of AI dystopia where robots
do everything and humans do nothing. There will
always be something for us to do and if there
isn’t, you can be sure as hell that we’ll make
something to do and that’s why the idea of AI
replacing everyone’s jobs is simply ridiculous.
AI content, however, is ruining YouTube. If you
wanna learn more about that, check out this video.